Ezra had me intrigued when he said that you may be working on something or
working on something big. Uh, and so he nudged me to ask you,
so I'm going to ask you, are you,
so the thing that came to mind for me is a new book, but it might,
but it sounded like it might be something else.
Yeah. I mean,
so I'm working on a bigger project that I'm really excited about,
um, which is looking at the ways in which,
um, our safety and this actually grows out of the last book. Um,
our safety net, um, uh, was sort of described,
it was constructed to be difficult to use. And lo and behold,
when you had a real crisis in which people need to use, um, benefits, um,
or safety net programs, right? So UI, something like that or snap,
um, that, that, that then it, you know,
the systems can't contain these people. Um, and just in general,
I think that, that the government, uh, is dysfunctional for a lot of reasons,
but one of the ways in which the government is dysfunctional is that, um,
it doesn't have a very good customer service, orientation, uh,
things like doing your taxes are really confusing necessarily. So,
yeah, Y right. Um,
we have this enormously over complicated health system in which you have to
fight with an insurer and you have to figure out, you know,
does your doctor take this, that, or the other it's horrible.
And the government is crucial in that. And then you,
you look at programs like snap or UI, and they're just a disaster.
And for this piece,
I was talking to some folks who work on these kinds of systems
in, uh, like Finland.
And they were just horrified that you might wait three months for UI benefits
here. It's like, literally unheard of there. And, and so, um, that's,
that's one thing that I've really been thinking about a lot this year. Um,
because I think it's in, in a lot of ways intentional, right?
We don't want the government to work very well. Um,
or at least a lot of people do.
I want it to work well, Annie.
You do historically,
many politicians have thought that these should be punitive programs,
that they shouldn't be ones that are easy to access or to use. And, and,
and it's, um, you know, a pretty paternalistic like, well, you know,
if you're unemployed and you need help from the state,
then you should have to go to this office and figure it out.
We don't want to make it too. It was a famous Paul Ryan line, right?
Like we don't want the safety net to be a hammock. Um, but, but I think that,
that,
that you can kind of back out and just see how little administrative capacity
the federal government has at this point. Um,
and the States that are administering federal programs,
and it's pretty horrifying, and it's a really hard problem to measure,
but it's like very obvious to everybody who ever interacts with any of these
systems.
Oh, we all heard the horror stories of people getting busy signals for days and
weeks on end, because they're trying to call their state unemployment office.
And the obvious question in my mind,
why the heck do you have to call someone to get your benefits?
Like what is going on here?
Like there should be myriad ways for you to access those benefits that do not
involve your, uh, getting frustrated dialing in.
And every time you call and get that busy signal,
it's an erosion in public trust, you know,
like w we're we're conditioned to think that things are supposed to be this
lousy and it's awful. Uh,
so you're writing a book about why things were designed to be lousy is
that [inaudible].
Hang on a story on it now. Right. Um, and, and it, yeah,
it's about, um, it's about, um, how it came to be that the,
the administrator that it,
public administration became the burden of individuals instead of the
government, because I think that that's functionally what happened. Um,
and I think that there's absolutely no reason for it.
It was a colleague was asking me, um,
why is it that unemployment isn't automatic?
So as soon as you lose your job in a layoff, you don't get unemployment.
And I was like, well, because we've designed it not to be automatic. Like,
there's absolutely no reason that it couldn't be automatic. Um,
and the same thing for a lot of these, these programs, right?
Like why isn't it that if you are a parent with low income who has a new
kid, that you don't just automatically get a payment from the government, uh,
to support that kid's nutrition and to make sure that you have childcare other
countries do that. We don't. Um, and so I think that,
that this really grew out of, um,
my thinking about this really grew out of the last book where,
where one of the cool things about UBI is it just volts over a lot of these
problems. Um, but absent UBI,
there are a lot of fixes that other governments have taken, um, uh,
lots of updates that other governments have made. Um,
and I think that there's like an obvious the role of the Republicans in all of
this is a little bit more obvious.
But one thing that I think is especially fascinating is that it's not like blue
States are a lot better on this front than red States, right. Um,
they have a lot of issues with administrative complexity. Um,
California has had an absolute disaster,
whether it's a UI system and people waiting months and months and months for
benefits. And, um, the problem is, is really systemic and multi causal.
And it touches all sorts of, um, programs, you know, um,
when you talk to people who are applying for asylum or people who are formerly
incarcerated and, you know, um, uh, are still involved in the judicial system,
it's all the same thing, right?
It's just endless red tape in a really profound way.
This, this to me is the issue, Annie, that you, me as,
or anyone else can just, we can beat the drum on this stuff because, uh,
everyone can see that our government is highly inefficient at delivering various
things, uh, to people.
And we are conditioned to think that's the way it supposed to be,
even though it's not supposed to be that way. And it hamstrings, uh,
the ability for progressives to effectively, uh,
both wind policy changes and argue for a bigger role of government
in improving our lives. In my opinion,
because even reasonable folks can look up and say, wait a minute. I get,
you know, like you couldn't get me unemployment benefits for weeks,
or I still haven't gotten them. I mean,
I hear these horror stories on Twitter all the time where people are like,
still haven't gotten them and it says September or whatnot. Um,
so we need to actually start paying attention to the mechanics,
like the nitty gritty.
It's one reason why you and I both like universal basic income because
I thought, well, if we champion a way to get value into people's hands,
then it's uniform and it's universal,
then we're going to figure out a way to actually get people that money.
And of course, everyone was a tenant of that money, you know, you know,
this would be like, they'd be like, where's my dividend. Uh, and it ends up, um,
uh,
building our capacity to actually add value in people's lives because you would
have to figure out the plumbing.
Yeah, absolutely. Um, and I think that there's,
there's a bunch of win-win wins here, right? If things are simple and automatic,
I, you don't need a bunch of civil servants to administer it. Right. Um,
and you can free the government up to do other things. Um, and we actually, we,
there's a ton of political science research. There's, uh,
a really great scholar at Cornell named Jamila missioner.
And a lot of her work is focusing on Medicaid and people's interaction with the
political system after, um,
after receiving Medicaid or working with the health system in general. And,
and we know one of the things that comes out of that is that in many ways,
interacting with our government reduces our interest in and confidence
in government, as you put it.
And there's even some evidence that it sort of dissuades people from voting and
disconnect them from the political process.
No way. They're like, I want nothing to do with this.
Exactly. And I think that there's this really interesting,
kind of like thought loop that you get in,
in which like public services are terrible and it erodes your confidence in
government, and then it becomes self justifying, right?
Like why would we want to put any more administration into this if the
government can't get anything right.
And I think that you can look at sort of positive cases of where the government
does get stuff, right? Like actually,
most people who have Medicaid are pretty happy with it.
I'm old enough to remember when the argument about Medicaid was that it wasn't
insurance worth having, but it, isn't sure it's worth having.
And people actually really like it. People are very happy with Medicare.
People are very happy with social security.
People are very happy with public libraries, for instance. Um, so like,
shouldn't we be setting that standard.
Shouldn't everything be as efficient and transparent,
and non-punitive non paternalistic as social security, right?
Like this is the argument for, for UBI, but you can,
you can make other changes, um,
to sort of nudge you in the direction.
So one change that I think we don't talk about very often,
but I think would be really good is that I think TANIF,
which is our cash welfare programs should be eliminated and replaced with a
child grant. Right. You should not have to apply. You should not have to, um,
you know, meet these really onerous, terrible work requirements.
You shouldn't have to interface with,
with a welfare office that in many cases, um, might,
might have some preconceived notions about you. If you,
if you are a person with a kid, we should just give you the help. Right. Um,
and, and we should take away all of the red tape and the judgment and the,
everything that goes with it. Um,
and so I think that that's probably the clearest case. Um,
TANIF is a really unworkable, punitive, terrible program, um,
depending on which state you're you're in. Um, and,
and it's also not big enough, right? Like it doesn't, um,
actually help enough people get out of poverty. Um,
cause it's been kept at this amount since 1996, uh, the same, the same, um,
amount, uh, gets appropriated for it every year. Um, and so big. Yeah,
I think as a general point, like making government work for people is,
is not necessarily a focus of our political system, but it really.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.